the security operation has been running
over many days already
now the final crucial test lies ahead
police hope they have every angle
covered
no possible weak point left exposed
in the metropolitan police special ops
room staff are in contact with every
officer on the ground as part of our
planning we have thought about a whole
range of potential scenarios
that includes you know crowns and the
numbers that will be they'll be
attending of course crime and clearly
considering any threat of any terrorist
attack and our policing response not
just by ourselves but us working with so
many other agencies and partners is
absolutely key to ensuring this is a
safe and secure environment
more than 10 000 police officers will be
on duty for the funeral most of them
from the met
but it's a national policing operation
there are reinforcements from forces
across the uk
every specialist unit is deployed
and military personnel more than 2 000
of them
there are 500 foreign dignitaries to
protect it's thought perhaps a million
people will be watching on the streets
and they are being urged to play their
part you are our eyes and ears if you
see anything
or hear anything that you think oh
that's slightly out of the ordinary or
something that's suspicious please speak
to one of our colleagues and we'll be
able to respond there'll be extra
security for guests entering westminster
abbey for the service
visitors who'd claimed an early spot
outside the abbey were worried police
wouldn't let them stay overnight we've
been told that they're going to clear
this space so they wanted to go by the
treasury which i feel is very unfair my
daughter came here earlier on she got
told something else he's two ladies here
have been told something else the police
presence is fantastic but i think they
need to
all be on the same hymn sheet if you
know what i mean we've come a long way
to see this and
if they stand in front of us we're not
going to see
the superlatives are flying around the
biggest policing operation the most
officers on duty the greatest security
challenge the reputation of the met is
at stake so too
british policing the security operation
has been planned reviewed and rehearsed
over many years
nothing they hope has been left to
chance
martin brunt sky news westminster